I always say to the people who tell me I
don't need to exercise I don't need to
do this I don't need to do that because
I believe in you know cellular
reprogramming is going to totally rescue
me in 10 years I say if you're right
that's wonderful MH if you're wrong you
won't have a chance to come back to
today and undo the damage so what's the
downside in doing everything in your
power to extract as much value as
possible out of the current you know
rudimentary tools like exercise
nutrition sleep Etc mhm and if you show
up in 10 years the worst thing that's
happened if the moonshot is there is
that you've wasted 10 years taking care
of
yourself contrast that with the
alternative asymmetry which is you screw
around for the next 10 years and there's
no moonshot now the worst thing that
happens is you're on a very quick path
to death right these are these are
completely asymmetric